hey youtubers is Charlie so for my Game
of Thrones bonus video this week I
wanted to talk about the East and Murray
just because this is gonna be a big
Daenerys episode episode 3 that is so
I'm gonna be focusing mostly on the
history of the ghiscari Empire as it
evolved into slavers Bay in Mereen if
you're totally finding me for the first
time I'm just doing bonus videos for
each new episode of Game of Thrones I
also do episode reviews and QAS be sure
to subscribe to get everything
I'm even doing a weekly Q&A the next
round starts whenever I post my episode
3 review later tonight that'll happen
after the episode airs so for this video
I'm assuming that you've watched
everything up to season 4 episode 2 so
potential spoiler alert for anything
that happens before those events so
let's start with a little history on the
ghiscari Empire they were the first big
great civilization that predated the
Valyrian Empire the pyramid that we saw
in the trailers is an example of their
architecture that survived to current
day in a generalized way I think of them
as like Egyptians that were later
occupied by the Greeks and eventually by
the Romans I think of the Valerians is
more like the Roman Empire every time I
think of the doom of Valyria I always
think of the fall of the Roman Empire
even though those two events are
completely different you know very
different reasons why both those empires
fell Valyria was basically physically
obliterated by acts of nature and the
Roman Empire just got too big to
maintain effectively again in real life
very different but biggest khari
architecture mirrors a lot of the
pyramids and their harpy statues remind
me a lot of the Egyptian sphinxes most
of the big khari cities were destroyed
in wars with full area which is why
there aren't a lot of physical reminders
of their existence with the exception of
you know the pyramids and some of the
cultural aspects like in the slaves as
well as in the unsullied I'm actually
really excited for this week's episode
because we finally get to see those
unsullied fight based on the clips in
the trailers it looks like it's gonna be
pretty badass
from a historical perspective the
unsullied kept a lot of the fighting
traditions from the ghiscari most
notably the lockstep way in which they
fight like an infantry basically they
also use a phalanx formation when
they're not using siege engines and
catapults so you can see george RR
martin is mixing and matching a lot of
bits from different histories because
the unsullied descent from what you
would consider Egyptians and the Phalanx
was a Greek fighting technique you
probably saw them use it in the move
300 siege engines kind of came from
Assyria and catapults were also
something from ancient Greece so the
reason why Daenerys has been marching to
each of these new cities and trying to
free slaves is because slave trade is
the primary source for income for most
of the big cities the reason all that
slaving got started was because of the
wars with the Valerians whenever the
ghiscari were finally defeated the
Valyrian sowed salt into all the soil so
that they couldn't grow crops anymore so
everyone had to turn to something else
for income you know thus you end up with
the slaving cities which included a
stupor young Chi and marine those first
two cities we saw in season 3 remember
how Daenerys flame-broiled everything in
sight so that brings us to right now
outside the gates of marine the last
stop on Daenerys quest to end slave
trade in the east or at least in slavers
Bay the difference between this city and
those other two is that it's much bigger
just as a point of reference marine in
terms of size is as big as young Chi and
a stupor combined so it's massive so
it's a good thing she brought all this
unsullied because she's gonna need him
remember in episode 1 when they were on
the road and stopped to look at all
those crucified slaves the officials in
marine had been tracking Daenerys
progress so they used this scorched
earth defense against her that means
they basically nailed up all those
people and destroyed the land
surrounding the wall so that Daenerys
wouldn't have any natural defenses so I
don't want to talk too much about what
the plot is going to be we can save that
for my review video which I'll post
after the episode airs but let's talk a
little bit more about the city itself
because it actually has some really
awesome landmarks first off there's the
Great Pyramid which we've seen already
then there's the temple of Graces in the
fighting pits the three big main
locations the temple is just a religious
building that we might get to see soon
but the fighting pits are exactly what
they sound like they're part of a
gladiator style combat arena just like
the Greek Coliseum so there's also a
whole lot of culture and marine to that
we need to talk about but I think I'm
gonna save it for a future episode
videos I just I don't know how far the
story is gonna progress in each episode
so I want to say things like you know
sons of the harpy as well as all the
slaving families isn't the harpy himself
so we can talk about those in future
videos we have seen a little bit from
inside the city in the trailers most
notably night scenes but imagine a
stupor and young Chi being a walk in the
park compared to the problems Daenerys
is gonna face a Marine
not only does she have to defeat the
city's official forces outside she'll
have to deal with the guerrilla
organizations and urban combat when
she's inside the city most of the
fighting that we've seen on Game of
Thrones on the show so far in Westeros
and in the East has been open field
combat we haven't seen a lot of urban
you know close quarters combat urban
combat is something that's just totally
new to most of the people of Westeros
even the unsullied aren't really meant
for urban combat
that's where Daario comes in think of
him is like a Special Forces leader in
Daenerys army even though I'm sure grey
worm would do just as well in any
situation by himself so here's a couple
things that I'm really excited about in
the episode that I think you guys should
pay special attention to first the
fighting style of the unsullied we've
really only seen them March Daenerys
isn't using the rod of control anymore
but she still is giving her orders to
grey worm and he gives those to the
group leaders and so on all the way down
to the regular foot soldiers
you know chain of command infantry style
this will look very cool and big
wide-open scenes second the fighting
style of Daario and the stormcrows
remember they're mercenaries so their
fighting style is going to be very
different from the unsullied but they're
both gonna look super cool we did get a
look at his blades whenever he and grey
worm were having that contest in Episode
one he unlike grey worm is capable and
negotiator too which is why he's better
for more you know small important
missions and grey worm is better for the
all-out open war and third the
architecture of marine I didn't actually
see a lot of the physical sets that they
filmed those scenes on but the CG and
the trailers doesn't even do the city
justice it's amazing
think of like a larger much much grander
version of King's Landing with a
freaking pyramid in the middle of it
that trailer scene with Daenerys inside
the underground structure is also from
the pyramid so maybe not in this episode
but pretty soon we'll get a really good
tour of the city if you've ever traveled
to any of the really old cities in
Europe you know what I'm talking about
there's just something about the
architecture there's just so much cooler
than the newer cities that you would
find in America so I actually think of
murine is like a mixture of ancient Rome
and ancient Egypt just from an
architectural standpoint but let me know
what are you most excited to see in the
episode remember Daenerys is only part
of the story we also have the aftermath
of the purple wedding in King's Landing
and we have Jon Snow in the wildlings in
the north so there's actually quite a
bit going on I'm expecting you know most
what happens in this episode to carry
forward into the next episodes because
it seems like there's too much going on
for it all to be contained to one hour
so like I said I'll be posting my review
after the episode airs tonight probably
around 9:30 p.m. Pacific time be sure to
subscribe to get it and feel free to
leave me suggestions for future bonus
videos to do right now click here to
catch up on the purple wedding and click
here for my Q&A video thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives